[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the the royal tombs of the new kingdom
appear to be models of the netherworld
we actually know this because the
architecture of the tombs matches the
architecture of the netherworld
in the book of the hidden chamber the
text that we often refer to as the Amjad
so on the walls of some of the tombs are
a type of Illustrated religious text
prototype for the very architecture of
those two when we think about Egyptian
funerary text we I think most people
think about The Book of the Dead which
the ancient Egyptians called The Book of
going forth by day but there's a whole
additional tradition that we have to
talk about that culminates in the New
Kingdom royal tombs in the Valley of the
Kings so it actually starts as early as
the fifth dynasty the final king of the
fifth dynasty a king named nas is the
first thing to have Pyramid Texts so to
have spells and rituals written down
inside his burial chamber and then those
pyramid tax many of them continue into
the coffin tax which then continued into
the Book of the Dead with additional
spells added but the netherworld books
are an entirely separate tradition so
you can't really say that the Pyramid
Texts become the coffin tax become the
book that did although some spells
actually do that like new ones come in
as we go new ones coming in and some
stay the same this kind of architecture
and text relating that there being a
significance not just of what a text
says but where the text says it and
that's why reading text out of books can
be somewhat misleading because those
texts in a book on the pages are in
three dimensions in the original
Monument
so getting to see what they look like
and some of the amazing 3d models that
are being made available now through the
Ministry of Antiquities in Egypt you get
a sense to be there you get a sense of
what it's like to be surrounded by these
texts in a larger architectural setting
another interesting thing to point out
is that there isn't an idea that there
is a single there's a book of the
Pyramid Texts and that's it because each
pyramid has a
slightly different grouping and
additional text may come in and some
text may not appear again or may not
appear in that particular Monument and
when we look at the netherworld books
that becomes overwhelmingly significant
because the book of on duat you will
also hear about the book of gates the
book of caverns the book of the earth
also known as creation of the solar disk
all that these texts describe the same
twelve hours of the night
but in radically different ways there
are overlaps particularly on Diwan and
gates but there's also these huge
divergences and for the egyptians it's
not as if one is right one is wrong one
is from one place one is from one group
of priests but they take a multiplicity
of approaches when thinking about
something that is by its very nature the
beyond the interesting thing about the
netherworld books is that although they
are concerned with the Duat although
they are concerned with the nocturnal
journey of the Sun they are in many ways
primarily a solar text and they revolve
frequently if not exclusively some of
them around this concept of
reconciliation of life and death the
joining of the god Osiris who is equated
with yesterday and the god ray who is
tomorrow the male/female elements of the
solar disk the e10 Ismael decoct the
corpse the horizon the akut as the
female elements this reconciliation of
cosmic opposites to achieve a MOT that
brings about rebirth a number of the
royal tombs have been open really since
the end of the New Kingdom
apparently during the greco-roman period
when a lot of visitors came to Egypt
became a tourist attraction the tombs
were visited there are a number of
greco-roman graffiti in the tombs and
the Greek term for a tomb in the Valley
of the Kings was syrinx feet long -
going into the
on the side the Greeks named Egyptian
things rather odd terms sometimes like
obelisk the sky piercing tessin is
called in Greek obelisk meaning a meat
skewer a roosting spit kebab stick I
love this idea of greco-roman tourists
and we know that there were guides that
local Egyptian priests would give tours
of Egyptian monuments Herodotus and his
histories records talking to priests and
getting tours of ancient sites so just
how tourists today visit the Valley of
the Kings in Greek times and Roman times
visitors would have gone and
unfortunately this idea of graffiti
izing of adding your name to an ancient
monument has a multi thousand year
history in the greco-roman period the
tomb of Ramses the 6th seems to have
been one of the more popular places to
visit and it was actually known as the
tomb of metempsychosis as though there
was a concept of wandering of the soul
and ancient Egypt as though they were
possibly even some concept of
reincarnation that doesn't really seem
to come out of the Egyptian text as such
but the tombs did receive name so Ramses
the 6th tomb for instance is treated in
some texts I believe is the tomb of
memnon and all of the West Bank would
even be called the Magnolia the realm of
memnon possibly based on epithets of
some of the wars is Mary Amon and
beloved earth that's fascinating and the
two really famous statues of Amun hood
of the 3rd the colossi often erroneously
called the colossi of memnon is only one
colossal exactly only one only the North
Colossus was actually memnon so both of
the colossi were in front of the
mortuary temple of Amun who the 3rd who
had a golden age in his 38th year ring
although his tomb in the Valley of the
Kings is fairly rarely visited because
it was in the West Valley so this idea
of us
it's statue was interesting because
although in the greco-roman period the
northern colossus of amon attempt to
third was called memnon the leader of
the Ethiopian contingent fighting for
the Trojans even though the northern
statue is the divine image in the
greco-roman period we know from
inscriptions on the backs of the classes
of the southern Colossus that the
southern statute when erected in the
reign of Omnitech the third the southern
statue has its own name and is a
divinity in its own right by whom the
king himself may be said to be beloved
and this brings up a really interesting
ancient Egyptian practice which is the
ritual of the opening of the mouth and
this is something that we see in the New
Kingdom royal tombs it is certainly
something that we see in private tombs
and you could perform the ritual of
opening the mouth both on the mummy
which is how we traditionally think
about it as well as a statue so for the
Egyptians doing this ritual of the adds
that's being touched to the mouth of
either the statue or the mummy that
enables the mummy or the statute to
receive the spirit of the deceased or
the spirit of the reigning king this
goes to the heart of ancient Egyptian
practice that an image of representation
of a person or a king or a God could
receive the divine spirit
[Music]
when you walk into an ancient Egyptian
royal tomb in the Valley of the Kings
you go through a series of descending
passageways and the architecture beyond
that can incorporate the angle change
that we see in the 18th dynasty or
simply a jog in this series of
descending corridors and the very first
corridor is called the path of shoo now
shoo is the god of light and space we
could even say the god of luminous space
and he is the god who stands between Deb
a God who can personify the earth and
Newt a goddess who can personify the sky
and remember that these tombs would have
only been visited during the actual
funerary ceremonies as well as by
Metroid who patrolled Valley of the
Kings and check to make sure that
nothing had been disturbed in the tombs
but otherwise they were sealed the
rituals the ceremonies those were taking
place in the mortuary temple but at the
same time those first two corridors of
the pathway of Shu are where we see
representations of the forms of the Sun
and a text that we call the book of a
drawing Bray in the West or commonly
called the litany of Ray the first is
the ancient title the other is the
conventional modern title the
netherworld books as we call them that
adorn the walls of primarily the royal
tombs of the New Kingdom although they
have occurred elsewhere and later as
well these texts we call the netherworld
books begin to appear around the time of
hatshepsut telmo's the third she's a
great innovator she does seem to be we
have blocks associated with one of the
burials of top-most the first that have
the book of um droite on them the book
of the hidden chamber and then we also
see both the book of the hidden chamber
and the book of a Dory ray in the West
in the tomb of oyster Amon Tubman's the
Third's vizier which is one of the very
few times we see it in a private - and
it's interesting that the book of the
hidden chamber contains directions as to
how it is to be laid
out on wall and it also contains some
instructions as to how to lay out
apparently this index that appears along
with it and it's rather interesting
composition we don't really know the
origins of these tacks some people have
tried to push them back much farther
than their earliest occurrences others
assume they probably date to just about
the time of the earliest occurrence
grammatically it doesn't seem likely
that they existed in their present form
prior to the Middle Kingdom and this is
an important point as well that when we
think about pure area text in each
natives most people would think Book of
the Dead that that's the classic the
papyrus scrolls with various spells
showing you how to pass the gates
transformed into a scarab go through the
judgment hall chapter 125 where your
heart is weighed against the feather of
truth against mod but that's a separate
tradition from the netherworld books so
the Book of the Dead can occur in New
Kingdom royal tombs in the Valley of the
Kings but it's a much smaller percentage
of the wall space right it says I mean
interestingly on the second shrine of
Tutankhamun that contains one of the
three versions of a cryptographic
netherworld book that revolves around
this concept of the union of R and
Osiris we get a mixture of cryptographic
netherworld text and book the dead
passages so there are just hieroglyphs
there are cryptic graphic hieroglyphs
right and we'll talk about that
[Music]